pour enfin direction avec ce en provence
pour le festival et une dernière
création très attendue
il s'agit de l'opéra de béla bartok le
château de barbe-bleue il sera marqué
par la rencontre de deux monstres sacrés
car boulez et pina bausch reportage
dominique poncet avec lui la fosse
d'orchestre est encore vide mais tout le
monde à coeur battant les invités qui
piaffent à l'entrée les jeunes musiciens
de leurs caisses du stade malheur parce
qu'ils vont être dirigés par pierre de
l'aide et que ce n'est pas rien inaba au
parquet de la mise en scène et les deux
chanteurs qui vont incarner barbe-bleue
et sa nouvelle épouse parce qu'ils n'ont
pas l'habitude d'évoluer au milieu de
danseurs
le hongrois là le pôle gare souhaite une
traditionnelle toytoy à sa partenaire
we have du cool c'est un vieil a donc
fait du rôle sa mort j'ai chanté plus ja
plus que ce enfants
j'aimerais calculer combien poids mais
c'est sur ce plus que cent fois
d'entrée de jeu c'est la stupéfaction on
ne sait plus si on assiste à un opéra
signées bartok ou a eu un énième
chorégraphies de pina bausch
pierre boulez dirige avec sa rigueur
habituelle et sur scène des corps se
tordent autour des chanteurs la mise en
scène de la danse et la musique
mais les chanteurs
parfois ces croisés par quoi ces
parallèles c'est difficile pour lui
aussi six îlots conventionnels comme
toujours les gens quand ils arrivent ils
je suis sûr qu'il y en a qui m'a dit ah
mais il ya deux personnages et puis
cette porte voix pas les sept portes les
deux personnages sont multipliées par
des chanteurs par des danseurs pourquoi
faire ça et bien
ne serait ce que pour les faire
réfléchir c'est très bien
il y a longtemps que bien roulé ce défi
n'a pas où je voulais travailler
ensemble c'est fait ils sont heureux et
bien au dessus des controverses qu'ils
pourraient bien déclencher demain soir
pour la première